thank you thank you
thank you very much as I already talked
it it should be mostly a life coaching
session like we have maximum 10 millions
of slides and then live coding and this
life Quantic we will do without an
actual ID because my machine is terribly
broken I can't install anything I won't
have even after completion and I won't
have by spark installed on my mission so
we will improvise the whole stuff but
first of all yeah who am I yeah
if you don't see me from there from the
uh from the rows far away from me I look
like this
and I actually not look like this I like
this photo more than actually me
Photoshop makes absolute magic to me I'm
a developer avocado a general brains
usually we don't fail our life coachings
like this but I did it I somehow managed
to completely break my machine
uh I'm I'm an average fight and enjoyer
I mean I'm not so long with python maybe
four years or something like that
I can I can write some code in Python
maybe even in Jungle maybe not who knows
uh definitely I am good in Python for
data engineering I can definitely write
a code for airflow if you know what it
is and if you don't it doesn't actually
matter also I'm a speaker and streamer
at the same time I speak at conferences
I speak in podcasts and I stream things
on uh to each and on YouTube you can
find our twitch by this three module URL
brains
yeah actually my friend he's probably
not here today but we are streaming uh
how he he's he's a real pythonist I mean
he writes code in Python for many many
years and now he learns to how to write
a code in kotlin and it's kind of kind
of funny to watch and I'm trying to
learn from him how to actually create
games
and also I'm data engineer and it is
what leads me to this talk and to talk
about data because you know people
sometimes think that data engineering is
something hard it's something difficult
to understand and maybe not even very
useful for you like who who are data
Engineers here
nice and cool backhand engineers
and data scientists
okay awesome
so folks who are data Engineers probably
won't hear many new things today
probably they will but I hope not I
think that you are already working with
spice park at some level
but a lot of them
yeah
I think that you don't need data
engineering skills
it's it's just a clickbait you can't
actually click it but it's just a
clickbait
because uh you don't need data
engineering skills until you do
I mean what what what actual data
engineering skills well that's data
modeling like how should we put out the
18-hour warehouse and actually Warehouse
can be your small postgres or even dick
database it's so it's it's already data
modeling
data architecture nobody knows all the
pipelines all the stuff
handling large amounts of data well
nobody knows what is large amount of
data I don't know what is large amount
of data actually sometimes I say that if
you work on like
very old machine one gigabyte is a huge
amount of data for you and basically
it's true and you don't need the skill
because you usually don't work with such
a big amount of data
uh jvm yeah lots of data engineering
tools are built on top of just Samsung
jvm even airflow you write the whole
code for airflow in Python at least I do
but the gdbc connectors uh like job ones
right it's crazy that pure python
technology is built on top of jvm of
course by spark is built on top of jvm2
spark is written an awful scholar I
can't even say how awful it is but it
works I mean kinda kinda nice
uh debugging I know some people all
kinds of debugging actually I mean
print debugging prints are counted as
debugging too I usually sell this point
for pie charm that we have step-by-step
debugging given on remote machines but
probably you don't need it I don't need
it usually I just set up one print and
it's not there something is broken
before nice SQL okay I believe that
everybody works with this girl care who
who doesn't work with SQL
okay one person thank you thank you for
being an honest it will be Car Talk for
both of us
by the way you can see the link at the
bottom left it's actually my link tree
for you to be able to get all my
contacts sent and not give me feedback
how all for my presentation was
and uh did did another I didn't mention
the actual Big Data I don't like Baba's
words first of all but also it's
completely relevant to my talk because
Pius Park is not about handling Big Data
yeah you can handle big data with it
but it's not the point
even distributed things distributed
compution computation is not about
is not what my talk is about
my talk is about uh
I don't know users of Pi spark for mere
mortals by the way all the images in
these presentations uh generated with
majority thank you thanks me Journey for
version pad version 5.
I mean photos are much more nice
uh Pi spark allows us to work with big
data yeah but
it allows us to work with big data like
it's small data but
it's a seamless distributed manner like
you usually don't care about how is the
thing working this in this difficult way
you don't think in your code in a
distributed way you just do your usual
function calls
and it does the trick
and yeah the it has only one basically
new idea in in it compared to usual
python development it's a concept of
data frame
data frame is basically a distributed
collection of data organized in the name
columns I didn't even understand what
does it mean I mean
it's very complicated way to say that we
have our data distributed all over the
all over the place I mean several
machines several date nodes several data
centers nobody cares yeah what's
important it's immutable we cannot
change data inside the data frame like
if it is there it is there we can remove
data like remove columns or remove rows
from it we can add more columns we can
somehow add more rows to it
um we can filter group join stuff like
everything we can do in SQL usually
usual data converts that I'm not
teaching you this stuff and yeah thanks
to charity PTO this is the basic example
of data frame at the bottom of the slide
like four columns ID name H and salary
and what we can do on this data I don't
know we can add one new column like
twice as salary and for John Doe it will
be a hundred thousand congrats to John
Doe on having a huge salary yeah he's 32
and probably white male I don't know
so yeah but what we can't do we can't
change his actual salary of John Doe we
can we can set we can't say inside our
data frame that now your salary is 87
000 we should create in Euro or new
column with a modified data somehow and
then we should drop the old salary
and
it was a little bit a little lie that
it's only about data frame because
yeah actually spark gives us a
distributed computation engine it means
that basically we can solve any
computational task in spark and
distributed computational tasks can or
not distribute it if it doesn't
distribute Fibonacci numbers are
perfectly possible to do in spark I
don't know why would you do so but it's
it's possible or if you need to Traverse
some huge graph I don't know insane
graph virtual you can do it in spark
and this is what makes it so popular as
well as it can connect to multiple data
sources you usually don't think about it
but
what many of you work with the
relational or non-relational databases
and then you grab some data from this
relational database
and you make some HTTP call to grab some
more data you enrich one data with
another data and now you have big ball
of data
which you should somehow process in your
own code all right this for Loop so
either tools by the way who use either
who use it or Tools in their practice
yeah that's what I thought less than
half
I actually don't like Hitler tools
because
I I should put one call of footer tools
inside another color filter tools I like
chains yeah I can come kind of from java
world it's fine there but Guida doesn't
like cold chains in your actual code
but sometimes it's just handy to to not
have many
um list comprehensions but to have one
thing
one thing after another
then spark
um can I don't know join data as you
like build execution plan for you and
execute it in hopefully most optimal way
it's it's a way to say that it tries it
best optimize what you are doing but if
you fail terribly it will fail for you
absolutely terribly even worse than me
uh why do you need it well
for example you already gave you
one day you will decide that you need to
join your data from your actual database
with
um some data from HTTP API and it's
possible
it's fully achievable with spark
maybe collect data from multiple sources
I don't know once upon a time I've been
working at some big bank and they had
lots of branches and they had to collect
data from all these branches and somehow
handle it all I wrote some terrible
thing I had a for Loop and HTTP call
inside this for Loop that will that will
put each Json into some list and then I
try to handle the whole list it's
actually not the best way to do it you
spark it could it would be much easier
or maybe
sometimes
SQL is not enough for you because you
need some function that is not available
in your dialect in of SQL
you know last days uh these days I
usually talk about that DB
an awesome sqlite for analytical
purposes
like it works on your machine it has
lots of analytical functions I believe
more than hundreds or almost has exodata
but if you use MySQL it happens to best
of us
there are like 20 analytical functions
it's not enough in pi Sparkle in any
spark you can write your own function
that will aggregate data as you want it
to be aggregated and yes of course it
can handle big data and by the way on
the picture you can see a spark ignites
Big Data
I I I couldn't even imagine that it's
the actual registration but yeah
so our today's sample and by the way
it's we just finished the best part of
our presentation that actually doesn't
fail
uh today's sample is moving smoothie
lens is uh recommender server
recommender service
that allows you to find
a movie that you will probably like
based on your cast or on your taste like
you set some Mark to each movie you
watched and they try to recommend the
next move you should watch
works not so bad but in their official
data set they have data only until 2018.
and so yeah
it's not completely up to date but
still I have a question
how do you think what is the most
popular genre of movies who thinks it's
comedy
uh two people three people four
action
okay folks uh for from let's say from
20th year to like
1920s to 2018 the last only last hundred
years
yeah so yeah action was like eight
people uh drama
uh okay like my people 10
um Western
one person okay
what else do we have uh Phil Noah
yeah I didn't even hear about it before
I started handling this data set
actually yeah it's it's a funny story it
appeared like in 40th year and
disappeared in 46 maybe it's I don't
know connected to war or something
was what else which are the most yeah
thrillers
okay and the horror movies
okay so drama and action are your most
popular choices I have remembered it
again I won't be able to show you the
actual demo
so we will improvise
I already have I I have like I had like
five minutes to download the data set
it's called Uh ml latest
it looks like this I don't know if you
can see anything do you folks know how
to enlarge anything in this yeah like
this okay nice
at least something comma can do so it
looks like this it's just CSV
with three columns
movie ID
title
and generous
yeah ID is just a number
title actually includes uh the actual
title and year when it's done
and generous is just a pipe delimited
thing
it's not sorted by time it's not sorted
by anything actually
we also have several more
tables nowadays that's uh what can be
interesting for us for example tags
I'm not very good with Max
give me a second
text look like this user ID
movie ID tag
and timestamp
yeah I will have another question about
text a little bit later if you will have
enough time because again presentation
goes terribly wrong
uh let's say that we want to answer our
question of what is the most popular
thing
in yeah I should probably go to
presentation mode at least
come on
give me a second yeah enter presentation
yeah like this
I won't even be able to show you that's
funny yeah so what we are starting from
is we should create a spark session
it's the thing
uh that allows you to actually work with
spark inside some spark context they
have a field Builder and we will call
ghetto create I wrote it so many times
so I that I memorize it and of course
yeah
wrong wrong yeah and it will be called
something like spark equals
yeah something like this
then when we have the spark we want to
load our CSV in our example it will be
CSV in your actual examples it could be
connection to database or something like
that it will go like this spark Dot
a read
it's actually a spark reader thing that
allows to you to read from something
then CSV
then we will have to put our path to CSV
here it will be something like movies.cc
I don't have an actual code so I don't
have to put an actual pass here
so and also we will pass a couple of
parameters there like header equals true
because we have header in our CSV files
and also in first schema
equals true
in first schema is kinda interesting
thing
spark can try to understand what are the
types of columns
we use in our CSV by their content and
obviously for movie ID it will be
integer or something like this
for other things it will be something
different
okay now we have and we put all the
stuff into
something called GF it's just data frame
which which will read from movies
what we should do next let's try to open
our movies again what I want to do I
wanna
split of this genres
by pipe
because I need to count how many
General how many entrances of each genre
there was every year
so it will be it will go something like
let's put it
yeah
in parents like the F Dot
with column
this way we will add a column to our
data frame that will create that will
contain a new content for us and our new
content actually is just split generous
for that we will call it this column
will be called I don't know generous
array
and we will put them
split
of column generous
by
backslash pipe yeah something like this
after this operation and I am not able
to show it to you because my ID doesn't
work we will have a new column generous
array that will collect that will handle
the whole list of array of generous for
instead of one big string
and let's call this
I'm terrible with Mac
with generous it's still a data frame
with one new column but by the way
probably we need to do something else we
don't need our generous column anymore
right
so we can drop it
it will go like this drop generous
because we don't we don't actually care
about it
now the next task our next next task is
when we have array
we should like convert this array to
several rows right right to a story is
action and comedy and animation on
something you should have Toy Story
Action Toy Story comedy Toy Story
animation and so on
for this we have very nice
function called explode in spark so it
will be like this with Jenner
equals
with generous
dot with column oh no sorry yeah with
column right
with column
it will be called Jenner
and here it will be explode
and we will use function called call
call is stands for column in pi Spark
generously
uh at this point we will have a
structure like
give me a second this
one Toy Story
animation
to
Toy Story
I don't know comedy and so on
I'm working for
does it work yeah nice I'm here I'm here
instead of spark for you like
interpreting the code like you do on our
interviews I hate coaching interviews
and now it's the worst coding interview
in my life I mean usually I have like
two or three interviewers max right now
here are like search interviewers
I hope that you don't know spice Park
and you can't find any mistakes there
also I hope that you don't buy don't
know Python and at this point because I
feel that I'm terrible in fighting right
now yeah so we actually have this I
don't know Toy Story was I believe was
1984 let's check question uh no it's
1995.
so I'm not that old
uh 1995. uh now we should put a year
into a separate column right I it will
be something very simple
some something like with gear equals
with General
dot with column
stupid pie chart you could already
understand that they have this function
with I mean I'm using it for the third
time
with column
yeah and surprisingly we have something
uh like regrets to extract
uh from which column from obviously
um title
what should we expect should we are
what what will be the actual regexp here
I believe it will be something like
uh backslash S Plus then backslip who
can read regular expressions
oh so yeah you don't actually care so I
will put some random stuff there
I mean for real
actually I'm just looking for this uh
for four sequential numbers at the end
of the line
uh probably there are some some more
spaces and the most important
end of the line dollar sign I mean they
should pay us at the end yeah and it
should be first group of March
and and at this moment we will have
almost the same stuff
please select it for me thank you
but with additional with additional
thing called like like this
also if we will look at our data set we
will probably
what the kind of name of movie is it I
don't know I mean how should I extract
it
yeah but we will probably find something
like
genres
yeah something like this no generous
listed we don't care about these lines
right because they don't benefit our
task we should remove anything with no
General with General no generous listed
we should remove anything with uh here
equals now it means that my regular
expression is not so good to extract the
gear in in every possible station
uh so we will take our with by the way
with here
and
yeah thank you
filter
I actually like how how it looks like a
filter column
dot is not now
yeah yeah I believe it's chemo case but
I'm not sure
and
column
Jenner
not equals no generous listed
in parents
Welcome to My Stream by the way it's how
my streams work all the time but usually
my ID works
at this point we have kind of clean data
set it's what data Engineers usually do
they should clean their data they should
they should validate it and say okay now
we can actually work with it
so let's call it clean
I'm not even sure yeah of course it
should be not double it should be like
this
yeah nice
now we should aggregate it somehow right
we should find
e find count of movies in each genre in
each year it will be something like
clean dot Group by
um we need a tuple here I think uh First
Column is here
second column is
General
logically
and we need to aggregate it
and it will be actually very simple it
will be something like call
title
dot count
and we will have something like I don't
know
comedy
one
and everything like this
yeah there were actually more comedies
so if we could launch if we could
actually launch this code if it wouldn't
be just a text editor right now we would
see that the actual
the the actually the most popular
General all of the time
is drama so those of you who guess drama
you can upload to yourself it was a good
job
yeah you you definitely know something
about movies I I didn't know I I thought
it will it would be coming there
but yeah I mean it is what it is right
we still have some time so the next
important I promised you that we
just imagine that we have executed this
code and it actually works for us but
now we want to understand a different
thing we have text for movies right
sometimes we have many tax formulas
how do you think which is the more which
is the movie with uh the most num the
biggest number of tags in it
like
I give you I'll give you a hint there
are more than 10 000 stacks
for this movie it's all user provided
content any ideas
do know something about trackers or I
don't know other people who enjoy movies
okay
cool
it will be a surprise I like it so we'll
now we will do the basically the same
thing
now we will uh we don't need to create a
new session we will
we will read the new data set again
like this
and we will call it text
and
the code will be very simple we have
already this clean thing we will join it
clean dot join
tags
does it remind you of anything
it's kind of SQL like thing right
yeah it's it it's actually a for me is
the most powerful part of spark we can
join everything with everything because
everything is just data frames
we should Define predicate there and
predicate will be actually very simple
movie ID
because they share this column movie ID
tags are a text reference movies by
movie ID and yeah it should be inner
join
it will it will go like this
then to then we need to aggregate what
do we need count text for each movie
so we will
Group by
and aggregate
by column
it's something like
array aggregate I don't think I don't
remember the actual syntax so we will
just stimulate it array aggregate
um
tag
let's say it's called Tech
and we will have uh something like I
don't know something like this movie ID
one text will be I don't know a b c d
now we need to
add one column
this column
the count
with the length
of our Tech
and this way it will be converted to
four we will have this
and also form
and this is an actual length of our
actual number of our texts for each
movie
that simple I mean I don't even know
which python chord should I write to
join things I mean while we were in this
we are in single CSV mode it was kind of
simple right just couple of four
comprehensions
for
comprehension instead of this uh explode
function and basically count gender by
year right but when we are talking about
joining sets it becomes not so simple we
should put something in dicts what
should be dict uh what should be key in
our logic is not very clear probability
how should we find deities in both dicks
and how much code we should write it's a
little bit obscure I mean it's like 10
lines of code where and here I need just
one manipulation of columns and that's
basically all and yeah the movie with
the most text is Star Wars number four
like first movie in the series
chronologically
uh and it has 26 something uh tags
thousands of tags some of them which are
incredibly crazy like they actually
describe the whole plot of the movie in
one tag
I I wanted to show you in in in the
actual idea and how it looks but
no luck here
so yeah sometimes for me and actually
this is the case
you can you can not only count things
let's say we have counted all the stuff
and let's say it's ready now we need to
to write it somewhere to our database or
to other CSV file it would it will go
like this ready dot right
Dot and no CSE
and
dot CSV
yeah and very careful about my
extensions when nothing works
and yeah it's done you can run it every
day because your data in your database
is actually updated right
you you should run it probably several
times a day and it's easier you can run
it locally you can run it inside your
actual backend application you can run
it inside I don't know some business
process just create once instance of
spark session and run everything you
need when it will go large of course you
can create a cluster of spark you can
submit your jobs there and so on
but it is already useful when you don't
want to mess with
for with the loops and ifs and so on
when you want to kind of declarative
approach to your data right
so yeah I think it's time to get back to
my presentation
because it's time for a small summary
I wanted to say that we saw some nice
nice plots but we didn't saw them here
so only my awful handwriting but by
Sparkle owes us to do several
interesting things it allows us to join
data from different sources in our case
it was two tsvs already not absolutely
trivial in Python but we can join data
from I don't know snowflake Oracle and
parquia files at the same time and for
spark it's all the same
we can process this date in parallel
it's important when we have a large
amounts of data we will launch our stuff
in in the cloud it will be massively
personalized on hundreds of machines and
it will run fast and for you code will
remain the same the same configuration
will be different code will remain the
same
and we can work with data in a uniform
way
thank you very much for being patient
for those who was patient and I think
it's time for your questions
[Applause]
all right thank you very much for the
talk
um there's been lots of questions uh the
first one I think that comes from all of
our hearts is you've passed the coding
interview with flying colors thanks for
doing this
thank you
[Applause]
all right so Christian asked the
questions
um what's your recommended way of
setting up a cluster and submitting jobs
with all dependencies like python
packages and database drivers yeah when
we're speaking about python I would say
that we have only one only one way we
when we have Java we can pack everything
in the fat jar and submit it but
otherwise we can we just should put our
main python file and all and all
satellite python files I know if you
have money and submit them and put your
jar files as one spell jar if it's
possible otherwise as single jars or
even if as dependencies if you have
local Arts Factory I would not recommend
to Def to depend on external
repositories and I would not recommend
to depend on libraries we already have
on in our cluster to me it sounds it
looks a bit fragile I had issues in my
experience with it
thanks nydia asks what would be your
tips to improve writing performance in
spark writing performance uh thank you
very much it's a very interesting
question uh and kinda deep I would say
that it strongly depends on our Hardware
if we work with some something not very
realizable we should probably
repartition our our data like you know I
don't know two or three big partitions
and write them slowly but surely if you
have something like S3 we can do many
many partitions and trade them at the
same time it but everything is depends
on our Hardware on our network drives
and so on there there is no you I don't
know single working recite
makes a lot of sense
um Anonymous ask would you be able to
provide this as a working example later
and if so where much appreciated uh for
sure it will be on my GitHub my GitHub
is as Monday uh please find me at my
booth at jetbrains and we will try to
arrange some something I will try to do
it tomorrow I wanted to do today
actually I wanted to put it on GitHub
today but my machine doesn't work
probably I won't be able to fix it today
so hopefully tomorrow uh please reach me
out in any in any way that works for you
and I will give you a link
cool
um another anonymous question is why did
we use spark for this example wooden
simple pandas or an airflow deck be
enough thank you for this question uh I
actually don't like pandas for several
reasons I mean pandas is awesome
everybody knows pandas is awesome but I
find it syntax confusing sometimes I I'm
not sure that everybody can like the
novice user can distinguish between
serious and the whole data frame but why
do we have two concepts when we can wire
one the lots of operators have ever
loaded it's not absolutely clear that to
another device user that we can rewrite
column uh just assigning it like in in
the center of course you can learn it on
each courses but the very fact that you
should learn it I don't like it and also
pandas are local
spice bar gives you this flexibility
that now you can work locally and
tomorrow you will go distribute it and
you don't need to do anything with it
but but changes but some minor changes
to your configuration or not so minor if
you write something complex
thanks another anonymous question
um how do you use custom functions in
spark
okay custom functions are called udfs
user-defined functions uh probably the
answer is when in pi when we are in
Python we don't but we can
uh why I said why do I say that we don't
use them in Python because there is a
cost of call
UDF from java to python it actually
pipes the whole data e the every row of
data through pipe into into the python
process and it's slow but see but still
it's possible it's totally possible to
Define udfs I would propose if you need
the custom functions if you lack
something to write it in Java or to use
some Java Library it's not that complex
you should Implement one interface with
one method and actually Java is very
simple language just do your stuff and
then cost will be like almost zero or
call of cost for the for this function
of course it won't be optimized as well
as Java to my spark optimizes its
built-in functions but for other stuff
it will it will work awesome
thank you another anonymous question
um you say we can run the code whenever
we need what if we want to automate what
tools can we use any orchestrator we can
open my weapon of choice is airflow Some
people prefer Dexter or prefect
and of course good old Chrome will work
too why why not I mean if you don't need
this Enterprises Solutions you don't
need you need to do something on one
machine just set up a chrome there save
to run each every five minutes your
python script and it will do it
all right another question by Nidia
um do you have a link to a repository
with the movies examples uh it is called
ml latest of course I have a link but
again everything is broken let me try to
try to find it in Safari
it goes like this movie lens data say it
says by this title you can find
basically everything you need and there
are some more interesting examples for
example wikileans that has some
statistics of Wikipedia and many other
things
all right and final question is there a
difference between using spark with
python versus Scala yes but it's more we
have two major differences first of all
spark is written in skull itself so you
can expect a little bit better
performance in color but nothing nothing
dramatic I mean most probably you you
won't notice it but there is more
important and more interesting aspect in
Scala or in Java we can use typed data
frames like as always in Java smart
compiler can check check types for us if
your column is is integer it won't allow
it to allow you to use it as a no date
for example or vice versa you won't be
able to use data's integer and call an
incorrect function on it in Python it's
possible but of course you will catch
your error on the with the first tail
test you you will write it's not that
big of from the issue still I prefer
type type thing type things when it's
possible and relevant
all right that's it with a question
let's thank the speaker again
thank you very much